frais à mon top 5 tours mais très
attention 3,2 à top non comme ça qu'ils
sont bêtes à aller plus vite plus haut
plus vite plus vite plus vite très vite
allez allez allez pas nerveux les mecs
un vide allez allez allez allez allez
ah ben alors là je vous dirais même qu à
ses vaisseaux alors je vous dis une
chose c'est un événement mais notre ami
nicolas pernikoff vous êtes éliminés
j'ai nous est terrifié et vous êtes
contents mais les qualifiés pour quoi en
fait
et bien pour la suite non ce bas pour
bal cd r j'ai compris je l'avais regardé
le tableau regarder l'aria du coup qui
va se qualifier bim
voilà qui se qualifie hélas au tour
suivant paf
ici vous ai compris
nicolas vous avez perdu ce défi je suis
triste vous allez revenir maintenant il
faut partir monsieur maintenant merci
beaucoup
les filles géraldine moi je te pas
tourné à cause de mon oreille gens
comment ça va ça commence à la rue plus
tôt peut pas tourner vas-y mais on veut
bien tiré mais sans tourner oui
saint-omer et scaër et allons aussi
c'est compliqué attendez non même au
talon pour enlever vos talons hauts
talons et vous faites faites juste ça ok
voilà et vous aussi faites pas les vous
faites le bâton voilà attendez attendez
attendez je vous respecte le principe
chez nous pas nous sommes nous sommes
dans un accord je suis là à l'or illégal
ont illégalement alors les i ça va les y
attend même pas enlever leurs chaussures
chaussures tout seul possible
allez-y alors je voudrais que mes
demoiselles je vois si l'on appelle le
principe de ce jeu
nous sommes à l'aube d'un match france
ukraine ouais donc nous célébrons le
football ouais ce soir on espère bien on
se fait gagner le match puisque c'est un
match qualificatif pour le mondial 2022
le mundial ok donc on fait un petit
chamboule tout ensemble
je vous rappelle que cyril hanouna et
déjà qualifié pour la finale ok et le
but et se qualifier avec lui pour la
finale alors delphine et géraldine vous
allez faire cinq tours arrêté deux
jeunes femmes claqué veux pas vous
claquez sur un florent chotard 6 janvier
r5 de vous à mettre le bâton comme ça
vous fait cinq tours vous vous à vous
faites doucement remonté à 100 jours
tout de suite on shoote d'accord avec
celle qui fait tomber de plus de plo ce
qu'est né ici pour le tour suivant ses
pairs excuses et claire oui c'est clair
attention trois 2 1 go un tour de tours
trois tours au cateau cinq jours c'est
mon jean
alors ce qui est amusant c'est que ça
n'a vraiment tout donné dans les tours -
dans le shoot
oui c'est ça et donc vous avez fait
tomber deux plots je crois moto c'était
pression des bravos géraldine vous êtes
qualifiés pour le tour suivant
non c'est très impressionnant puis c'est
pas clair c'est bien alors vous faudra
tourner un peu plus la prochaine fois
promis alors j'ai donc voilà donc
gérable géraldine fait d'affronter
gilbert la lire chez vous ont commencé à
mettre un billet savoir sur qui m'a dit
non ce serait un retour chez vous
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous projeter
pour le gagnant je rappelle que pour
l'instant c'est raide et au final donc
frais cyril contre eux une personne de
qualité bien évidemment que nous savons
déjà que gilles verdez été qualifiés que
gerald in my été qualifiés et le
prochain duos et bernard montiel qui est
là et là bonjour a opposé à guillaume
cannat voici votre bâton c'est un peu
votre nouveau permis mettez-vous en
place vous rappelle que nous avons voir
c'est quoi la compagnie sur deux jambes
ou le foot vous allez vous mettre à côté
enfin ce n'est pas dans la la la la la
la la ok vous allez faire cinq tours
mettant comme ça cinq tours est ok ça
ouais et une fois que vous avez fait
cinq tours vous devez shooter et abattre
le maximum de plots de sow mais si je
fais 5 tout genre la tête en l'air à ses
principes normal et c'est bien mais ça
veut pas mais en même temps en même
temps attention 3 2 a tourné un tour
deux tours 3 6 4
non c'est spécial en reste avec sa vague
idée soufflée président suez vous avez
très bien shooté merci et vous êtes
qualifiés merci vous des tirs a coûté
fait c'est en revenant comme ans est
tombé bas revenus non mais oui regardez
allez hop là attention babel et des amis
formidables
donc il restera plus qu'un un duo et là
j'ai très peur je vais affronter kelly b
devait ni dans ce champ bull photo la
justice y est dangereuse qu'elle est
très dangereux et très bonne
un très très bon très très bon très très
bon coupé sommes dans le sens où le foot
je rappelle que le vainqueur de cette de
ce premier tournoi rentrer sera opposé à
ces rides et nous là d'accord et il ya
un an
pour l'instant personne ne gagne puisque
c'est un tournoi 1 oui on agit leverdez
son âge
jean mallet à la dirigeante on est
maintenant entre vous et moi on va
savoir qui va se qualifier alors le
principe laisse un regard décalé venez
avec moi vous mettez 2 alors moi je rêve
aux gens les vrais vos chaussures à
talons voilà alors vous mettez comme ça
vous fait cinq tours et comme en effet
cinq tours vous shootez hockey celui qui
a fait tomber plus de plos qualifie
c'est facile on est à 1 2 3 go 28.4
hu
mais quel beau mais quelle mais quel
boulet je suis c'est pas possible
en même temps vous ai pas donné beaucoup
attendait comme je suis le patron là
maintenant on va le refaire
non non non non laiterie cheyrou non sap
apo le sujet aurélien terme
ben oui moi aussi en même temps à rien
d'aller voir fait vraiment les tours on
fera que trois tours mais fait c'était
vraiment à renens fait 3 ou et trois
tours mais vraies envies vos chaussures
alors attention 3 2 attendez j'ai pas de
ballons ah oui ça va trois a321 tôt 1 2
et 3 voilà bah là ça va beaucoup mieux
voilà c'est assez voilà là c'est logique
quand on appris que j'avais je vous
racontais bernard montiel bon prêcheur
vous êtes un tricheur j'avais gagné
ok qui ne sais quoi comme je suis un
gentleman
je vous laisse gagner c'est vrai à bâle
envie de faire je le fais ça me fait
plaisir
voilà il n'y a pas de raison ça fait
plaisir à la différence de certains
jeunes recchi pas les règles en
permanence merci beaucoup benjamin le
jeu donc
kenny bravo vous êtes qualifiés vous
allez affronter en finale ou en demi
finale soit vous allez affronter
bon c'est pas tout d'abord j'ai pensé et
ben oui alors non maintenant assister au
quart de finale entre gilles verdez demi
finale gilles verdez contre jallet
demain vous pressez le principe je vais
enlever deux tours parce que apparemment
ça vous donne envie de vomir et a pu
vraiment les petites choses près de
l'oreille interne brême d'estomac fin au
jeu c'est vraiment une équipe de bras
cassés monf avons donc trois tout mais
je l'aimé propres je n'ai vu comme ça
appliqué au quai ensuite vous shooter et
résultat est clair attention tagne et
met en place dans la tête sur le but à
boules croiser
1 à la bonne école ben oui 2 et 3
géraldine oh lalala lalala
alors là géraldine voilà je dois dire
que pour quelqu'un qui a besoin de rien
mais n'est pas et je n'ai pas de mots
clés interne
voilà je suis là je suis très très
heureux d'être là bravo merci vous êtes
est revenu au jeu très bien kanye est ce
que j'ai mis deux minutes et toujours
dans les parages
est ce que guillaume genton au scanner
frère on sera pas rater mes démons place
genton et là il est aujourd'hui au
téléphone oui il était bien les magasins
bio c'est donc la deuxième de finale
pour ce chamboulement foot entre
guillaume genton et les apprécie
impressionnant donc je vous rappelle le
brasier vous connaissez trois tours bien
la tête merci qu'amis et vous vous êtes
à majorettes du tout c'est de me livrer
sa pour l'instant alors il va alors on
équilibre en place dont on met la tête
sur la sur la bo la boue la boule ok on
fait trois tours trois vrais tours et
ont chaud d'attention demi finale attend
sur ces parties 3 2 dans la tête bull
oui et 3 c'est bon après quoi allez
allez allez
des objets en trois mots en allemand
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo à les
vaincre et 20 10 golf
donc bravo l'ultime finale on aura donc
un face à face entre guillaume genton et
géraldine maillet à mon avis guillaume
genton n'a aucune aucune aucune chance
si vous mettez vous trois tours voilà
cyril et là c'est bon non alors ben
antirides vos débuts à l'e3 de 1,3 taux
allaient à 2,3 à mais c'est pas comme ça
mais ils n'ont toujours pas compris
série mais où c'est que ce que je vois
voilà des nôtres n'ont même pas il a
triché
c'est tricher c'est pas comme ça c'est
comme ça ah bah ouais c'est vrai que
j'aurais dit les rovers ont offert voilà
bah non non non non elle est refaite à
les y aller j'ai allégé le groupe blanc
vera lynn vous allez affronter sert il
alors oui je vous rappelle son petit
chéri je vous dis avec toute attente en
syrie en fait ils râlent fourneaux et
magnéto et des kills à l'antenne un
petit sourire pas du tout comment ça va
être super content que tu veux dire je
m'emmerde rien gagné à l'attention c'est
parti rien n'est gagné attention 2 3 go
commun de tous autour du tout ses
lectrices pas moins ado ado avait
souvent possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]